exigeant théophile ben azzouz il est
directeur exécutif de médecins d'afrique
jean théophile bourousis merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors on
parle aujourd'hui de l'épicentre de
l'épidémie en europe où est-ce qu'on en
est en afrique
il est évident que pour l'afrique
comme on vous l'avait dit et plusieurs
personnes l'ont déjà signée on le
constate que les chiffres
d'épidémiologique honorifique
l'afrique a vraiment fait échouer
vous pourrez dire les pronostics qui
était souvent annoncée on a pensé qu'il
doit y avoir des millions de morts
heureusement enfin ne s'est pas passé
comme ça pour l'app store compte pas les
cas sont très très faible qu'on a très
peu de cas de copies de jeux d'hier
comparativement à l'europe et à
l'amérique je pense que nous devons
rester quand même très très vigilants
alors restez vigilants justement
pourquoi vous avez moins de cas sur le
continent africain par exemple sénégal
le niger où le cameroun ont mis en place
des politiques de tests ciblés
c'est cela qui a freiné efficacement la
progression du coronavirus ou pas
seulement parce qu'effectivement les
tests sont arrivés très tardivement en
afrique on était parmi ceux qui fait un
plaidoyer pour que les tests arrivent
parce que les médecins travaillent à
l'aveuglette
par contre ce qui a freiné véritablement
le virus je pense à mon sens c'est
l'action rapide des autorités publiques
qui ont effectivement c'était très
difficile à décider rapidement de fermer
les frontières de de faire des couvre
feux et puis aussi d'installer toutes
ces réactions rapides a permis à mon
sens de freiner les choses mais par
klaus pas seulement cela parce que tout
le monde le dit également
nous avons une population qui est
extrêmement jeune et encore ces virus
fait plus de mal plus
da auprès des personnes qui auraient
commandité et qui ont un âge un peu près
supérieur à 65 ans soixante dix ans donc
je pense que le l'afrique était sur une
bonne phase n'est pas seulement cela
il ya également la santé communautaire
qui est extrêmement développée d'afrique
a essuyé énormément d'épidémies
notamment ebola le choléra le vih et
aidera je pense que l' expertise deux
continents être aussi avérée notamment
dans la diffusion des bonnes pratiques
sanitaires un réseau dense de relais
communautaires ont été déployées avec
énormément de messages
la télévision a joué son rôle les
réseaux sociaux tout ceci a poussé à la
comptabilité individuelle et est-ce que
néanmoins les hôpitaux publics sur le
continent africain ont connu des
périodes de saturation de manque de
matériel comment est-ce que ça c'est
géré à ce niveau là il est vrai on
n'était pas préparés on n'était pas
préparé au niveau des hôpitaux parce que
les équipements sont très faibles et
système des systèmes de santé sont
fragiles et même on a constaté sur le
terrain vraiment une désertion des
hôpitaux parce qu'elle est un fan des
patients avaient peur de repas de partir
à l'hôpital et il a fallu faire une
communication rude pour les ramener à
l'hôpital non il n'y a pas eu en tout
cas une saturation par rapport à la côte
et 19
bien au contraire il ya une planche à
délaisser les formations sanitaires donc
les gens sont restés chez eux parce que
effectivement il y avait des corps au
furia une interdiction de sortie et il
n'y avait pas une confiance vraiment
fente auprès des vis à vis des
formations sanitaires de passe et les
médecins est ce qu'ils ont été davantage
consulté les médecins libéraux est ce
qu'il ya eu des traitements qui ont été
essayées comment ça s'est passé à ce
niveau là en tout cas il ya un peu de
médecins indique trop comme vous le
savez en tout cas en afrique
subsaharienne à rude épreuve
ils ont été bien sûr très souvent mots
dans l'effort solitaire de bave pas
seulement les médecins mais aussi des
infirmiers aides soignants évitera aussi
les agents de santé communautaires qui
ont été extrêmement mobilisés ils
n'étaient pas des progrès c'est vrai
qu'on a pas vu un nombre impressionnant
de contamination et surtout des cas
graves
on a même plutôt deux cas avec thomas
titre à 90% casino dont il était le
favori
est ce qu'il y avait des traitements qui
ont été utilisés bien sûr il est vrai
que pour la grande majorité même si la
consigne générale était de ne pas faire
le plaidoyer très officiel de l'isoc
security la vitre dessine peut-être à je
pense que la plupart des instructeurs en
tout cas des médecins
d'après mes sources en plus utilisé
l'historique euros qu'il assigne coupé à
la vitamine c est parfois ou donc
c'était le traitement le plus abordable
parce que nous étions en situation
difficile personne ne savait comment
aborder la situation et nous avons pris
des protocoles qui ont été un petit peu
à nous fait au maroc en algérie un taux
francs français oscille de part ses
routes et tous les autres en tout cas
les gens travaillaient en leur âme et
conscience pour faire face à ce qui
était difficile à organiser
est ce qu'aujourd'hui il ya tout de même
des inquiétudes quand vous voyez cette
seconde vague en europe notamment est ce
que vous vous préparez un rebond de
l'épidémie en tout cas il ne faut jamais
jamais jamais apprécié ça c'est très
important parce que si on leur foi la
population c'est contre productif les
médecins ne peut pas travailler dans ces
conditions là et d'ailleurs même la
surmédiatisation et parfois les fausses
informations qui sont véhiculées çà et
là je stresse tout le monde et je pense
que c'est contre productif
donc d'être vigilant bien sûr nous
sommes préparés et nous continuons de
travailler aussi en partenariat avec le
ms avec les institutions publiques pour
faire face à cette seconde vague mais on
le fait en tranquillité parce que c'est
rare de ne pas affoler les populations c
c'est vraiment un cri d'alarmé que je
lance
parce que en afrique ne pourra pas faire
face aussi à fait à fait à cette peur
c'était impossible
du côté de la population globalement il
ya une bonne acceptabilité de des
mesures annoncées des restrictions elles
sont bien vécu au il est vrai dans cette
difficile parce que confiné des pays où
le système de distribution de nourriture
n'était pas assuré ou les problèmes des
transports n'était pas assurée pour tout
le monde et c'était très brutal
c'est vrai que la population a
énormément souffert mais au fur et à
mesure que nous avons fait ou trouver
des solution intermédiaire lui il ya une
vraie acceptabilité on a un exemple d'un
projet qui a été financée d'ailleurs par
l'union européenne au togo où nous avons
monté des cellules des vins et citoyen
où toutes les autorités publiques et guy
compris coutumière se sont levés pour
sensibiliser mais la maison en tout cas
je pense qu'aujourd'hui gens comprennent
qu'il faut faire attention
il est vrai qu'une lassitude ya une
fatigue les changements de marc de fer
kovy teaser mais en même temps il voit
avec un gars très clair ce qui se passe
en europe les difficultés que nous avons
ici je pense que les gens se préparent
en conséquence et sont prêtes à aller
plus loin dans l'utilisation fin tout
cas d d d aider dans la pratique plutôt
des des mesures barrières merci beaucoup
jean théophile bonzi d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur exécutif de médecins d'afrique